the search for a missing college student
from Iowa is stretching into its third
week now 20 year-old Molly Tibbets
vanished on July 18th after going on a
jog in the small town of Brooklyn Iowa
while her case has captured the national
headlines thousands of others do not
receive this same kind of attention
Adriana Diaz is in Brooklyn Iowa with
the overwhelming scope of the
missing-persons issue
Adriana good morning good morning the
number of missing people in this country
is staggering one of course is Molly
Tibbets the reward for information
leading to her discovery has topped
$300,000 her case is bringing to light
just how many missing people families
are still searching for this year
started with more than 88,000 active
missing person records in the u.s. more
than 41,000 of the missing are under 21
years old that's enough to fill at least
495 standard school buses advocates say
law enforcement lacks the resources to
keep up with all open cases warning that
some can slip through the cracks one
that hasn't is 20 year old Molly Tibbets
who disappeared three weeks ago after
going on a jog in Brooklyn Iowa her
boyfriend Dalton Jack who's not a
suspect says she has no enemies and no
reason to run away I've never heard
anybody say a bad word about her and
never heard her say a bad word about
anybody people just loved her yeah it
was hard not to her disappearance has
garnered national attention because it's
rare says Robert Lowry of the National
Center for Missing and Exploited
Children we always have a very small
percentage like we're seeing with Molly
where they just simply disappear and for
no investigative reason or for any
purpose that we can determine and these
what makes cases like Molly's the most
difficult that anyone can face for
records entered in 2017 we're the reason
for disappearance is known 95.9% were
runaways and when one percent were
abductions by a stranger for those
missing under 21 fifty-three percent or
women 57 percent are white 37 percent
are black the situation with Molly is so
extraordinarily rare Laura Calderwood
and Robert Tibbets are Molly's parents
when you think about
the thousands of missing people that
there are right now in the u.s. why do
you think the whole country has focused
and rallied around Mali you know if
somebody put it it's the all-american
girl who lives in a Norman Rockwell
community in love with the boy next door
vanishes into thin air and so it doesn't
make sense this is where because she had
no reason to run away none none I'm just
got at least she was ordering sheets and
bedding from Target you know I've told
people I've got the sheets and I've got
the bedding but I don't have the girl
investigators have told us that they are
still conducting interviews and they are
revisiting leads experts tell us that
one of the challenges to locating
missing people is that most states are
not required to report cases to a
national database that's open to the
public
bianna be so frustrating but we know
investigators are combing through
hundreds of leads
Adriana thank you